i mean any decent drama school is going
to focus on getting a range in our
diversity amongst its acting students
and i think if you look at our three
nominees with david and with ruth with
benedict you've got a wide range of
actors there with different skills and
experience what they have in common is
they're all terrific actors and they
were trained at london
yeah but karen if you look at uh
hollywood and british actors we do tend
to see them in the more sort of period
roles perhaps all those ones with a
plumbing accent so isn't that what
hollywood loves well yeah of course i
mean you have to remember that that my
people have trouble with accents if you
have a thick glaswegian accent or a
mancunian accent we're going to need
subtitles so if you if you speak
posh-like we're probably going to get it
we don't really quite understand britain
it's a bunch of countries it's not just
england so we're really working with the
narrow field here we also like and this
is a long history goes back to to james
bond and also the bond villains we like
to think of english people english i'm
saying english as smarter than we are
and so that's why we like it it's a it's
a nice category that we feel comfortable
with but i mean cumberbatch and uh
redmayne both very good-looking i think
one went to harrow the other one went to
eaton posh place china i mean they look
good can they actually act
i think both of them are tremendous
actors yeah and i don't think it matters
where they went to school i think it's
the work they do on the screen oh i
don't think so no i mean i i would say
he's very different from playing julian
assange to playing alan turing i think
what british actors have which makes
them very distinctive is their ability
to transform i mean again if you look at
ruth or if you look at david a yellower
what they're doing there is a
transformation to play martin luther
king if you're a british actor i think
one it's tremendous honour to play that
role but two you have to be able to
transform to deliver acting of that
standard but cam before you came on we
were just discussing paddington which of
course doesn't qualify for this year's
nominations but it has that whole kind
of nostalgic
idealized notting hill feel to it
isn't that surely the idea that whole
idea that we'd like to have of brett's
on phil oh yeah cuddly living in 3.2
million houses you know with the stuffed
bear that talks sure of course actually
it's living there excuse me um uh yes
yes we do and and
and there is a reason for that and it's
it's cultural
again in america we have our own
underclass we have our we have our own
class issues not as
not the same as we have here but don't
forget for example you've got somebody
like gary oldman who's a very
well-respected actor who's a new cross
uh i can't remember which school he went
to
there you go but but there there is a
certain ilk of actor and for example if
you look at some of the uh the golden
globe nominations today you do see that
emphasize that's just this this tranche
of films that's what we have and also
don't forget americans kind of like to
categorize things and so makes it easy
for us